Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
There was a previous episode on a technique
where the inputs were a source video of ourselves,
and a target actor. And the output was a video
of this target actor with our facial gestures.
With such an algorithm, one can edit pre-recorded
videos in real time, and the current version
only needs a consumer webcam to do that.
This new version addresses two major shortcomings:
One: the previous work relied on depth information,
which means that we needed to know how far
different parts of the image were from the
camera. This newer version only relies on
color information and does not need anything
beyond that. Whoa!
Two: Previous techniques often resorted to
copying the footage from the mouth and adding
synthetic proxies for teeth. Not anymore with
this one!
I tip my hat to the authors, who came up with
a vastly improved version of their previous
method so quickly, and it is probably needless
to say that the ramifications of such an existing
technique are far reaching, and are hopefully
pointed in a positive direction.
However, we should bear in mind that from
now on, we may be one step closer to an era
where a video of something happening won't
be taken as proper evidence. I wonder how
this will affect legal decision-making in
the future.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!